there you go [ __ ] it's Tuesday
a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive December 27th the day the devil
was buried at sea rape to land our fire
[ __ ] in the ass hitting a head with a
hammer and dragged through the [ __ ]
water I got a [ __ ] the speedboat or
some [ __ ]
we're here with queer I haven't seen you
[ __ ] in a few days there's a
style of these people I don't want to be
bothering you I don't want to be [ __ ]
tormenting you oh yeah [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] I don't need to have been smoking
but you know we've been taking our time
don't forget the podcast is up the only
one we're doing all week it's up already
just merely the end the year I did [ __ ]
it my man Dave down team Delray Dave
Delray beandoor a last night and the
week is [ __ ] set next weekend I'm at
the Kaluga [ __ ] casino and
George Michael is dead and I don't feel
so good my [ __ ] self Cleveland
[ __ ]
pilot to buy the [ __ ] Bombardier I
got reefer four days
I got like ten bags will be for that my
man Detroit drop down man my man Ryan I
got some [ __ ] death from perennial I
got some lemon Cushman perennial we're
going deep this morning [ __ ] I don't
know what the [ __ ] you've been doing I
know you got that little Christmas
jingle money in your pockets go buy a
bag of weed and we'll do this all
[ __ ] we can understand me here's what
it's all about to get the [ __ ]
there's five days left in the [ __ ]
here but he's crying about 2016 suck it
up [ __ ] 2017 is your lucky [ __ ]
you carry fish you're dead Prince dead a
bunch of [ __ ] dead but guess
who's still alive you are and that's the
most important then you gotta keep
slinging digger well princess the gold
gives a [ __ ] you gotta keep slinging dig
[ __ ] you gotta keep swinging dick and
send them [ __ ] smoke signals you
understand me is that's how we [ __ ]
do it beside that I got a little juju -
today I got a spot tonight a flap as I'm
starting my little workout process to
get the next hour gone it's just a bunch
of ideas and every task room see closer
you know I'm feeling good the Christmas
holiday was good that got that
bullshit's [ __ ] over with now we're
on to the bigger [ __ ] package 2017
Trump this that this and how we're gonna
make him understand but Joey
enough with the CNN talk let's park a
boat all right already
let's finish this [ __ ]
let's finish the lemon push this morning
I got a little wheat score right from
here a little couple sacks thermal
village gypsum and it's that type of
[ __ ] day okay it's time to kick the
mule we gotta start all over again we
got 2017 you gotta take the sand out of
your [ __ ] eyes 2016 was a bad year
bliss all right
you're a lying [ __ ] that's all that
matters you're [ __ ] alive you know
what 1984 was a bad year for me but it
made me who the [ __ ] I am so sometimes a
couple bad things make you who the [ __ ]
you are that's what you gotta do
everybody is lucky because even when you
have a bad day somewhere down the line
you have a good day to reflect on that
[ __ ] bad they trust me I'm telling
you I'm not older than you [ __ ]
I think I got stories because I sat
around and played on a [ __ ] computer
on my life I got stories because I was
out there living mother [ __ ] losing
and living but eventually you start
winning and living and then you got more
[ __ ] stories so suck my dick and call
me shorty I was born in 1940 let's do
this [ __ ]
very nice very [ __ ] nice it's nice we
have this opportunity to get high
together yeah I'm saying
also my man all right Peter my man Ricky
Williams Ricky that dude was a funny
[ __ ] dawg
that dude was a solid [ __ ] and
that dude was better at comedy without
trying than most people that [ __ ] try
and they dip into the spirit animal and
they get the [ __ ] out here then
[ __ ] shot and robbed the house
that's why I'm running it from just show
up and rock the houses now there's no
inner light here the motivation I have
to tap into my pain suck my dick just
get up and do the [ __ ] job right like
all these black rappers you don't see
them [ __ ] go on acting class but they
get out there and drop it because they
don't listen to all that [ __ ] that
the motivation is the same the
motivation of the same was to even suck
my dick that was the motivation of the
same go [ __ ] yourself look nice see we
have a good time we smoke a little bit
we got our heads right and then we go to
[ __ ] out there and swing dick and make
the hole these [ __ ] hostages
and I said it's that [ __ ] easy we
think we should we smoked a little boat
can't leave the house on one foot and
then that just sucks dick
it's nice the sun's out my back is loose
they're being guy I'm gonna go [ __ ]
get choked out today if I don't choke
nobody people choke me out they twist my
arms at the end of the class mikey is
[ __ ] drenched even my kneepads smell
like [ __ ] my [ __ ] is rotten and
that's the most important thing I got
the blood going
I get that [ __ ] old toxins out of me
and that's it my brother you know where
he would quit God gave you another day
to live you're gonna sit there like a
[ __ ] half a [ __ ] talking well if chums
becomes present I'm leaving the country
who left the country nobody left the
country [ __ ] nobody's left yet it's all
[ __ ] these people just talking
everything you don't find here we
[ __ ] talk and we execute when I'm
[ __ ] around here talk and listen to
these [ __ ] jerk-offs they can all
suck your dick grab your dream and go
for it [ __ ] these punk-ass [ __ ] you
go you do whatever the [ __ ] you gotta do
you gotta drop the envelope off in their
office you gotta break into that car and
drop off your [ __ ] resume you do it
if you want that [ __ ] job
Oh
alright I'm stumped
what do you want from me now alright I'm
high we did the job and now you go out
there and stab [ __ ] without it
to remember just cuz they don't suck
your dick today I don't mean it I'm
gonna suck your dick
you got a plant to seed no suck your
dick down the road but if you got you
plant 18 seats look what you got plant
the seed every [ __ ] day and watch
what happens
these [ __ ] can't stop
and with that I gotta take two steps to
the rear and get out of here I love you
mother Fox I have a phenomenal [ __ ]
day don't let nobody getting away your
dream and [ __ ] 2016 there's just another
day and a [ __ ] Parkfield [ __ ]
my dust 2017 is gonna suck all our dicks
okay and maybe a bunch of piano players
to start dying or something like that
guys that play the food I don't [ __ ]
know I love you don't take [ __ ] from
nobody and tell them all to suck it
because at the end of the week
you're the captain curtly your
enterprise have a good day uncle Joey
loves you Kaluga casino January 6 by
Sacramento don't forget about me